deuxième phase du déconfinement lancé
mardi dans l'hexagone avec notamment la
réouverture des cafés bars et
restaurants avec des restrictions en
ile-de-france en guyane et à mayotte
depuis le 11 mai les mesures de
restriction on s'allège peu à peu
conséquence a lyon les quais du rhône
ont été pris d'assaut la semaine
dernière plusieurs tonnes de déchets se
sont accumulées
un groupe d'étudiants s'est mobilisée
pour lancer une grande campagne de
nettoyage dans la capitale des gaules
l'ouest à un ballon d'aller de khalifa
quand on aime sa ville on en prend soin
à lyon cette formule est devenue virale
pour les étudiants la raison plus de 6
tonnes de déchets thibierge chips
denrées alimentaires bouteilles d'alcool
ont été retrouvés sur les berges du
rhône le week-end dernier à ségou enfin
je comprends pas comment comment on peut
laisser ses affaires comme ça
franchement il ya des poubelles de
partout passés les autres leur site les
déchets
c'est une émission qu'on a vu à la photo
des équipes extrêmement sale on s'est
dit on pourra laisser se faire ça en
fait on la préfère quand il est bien
propre donc va avec instagram on a fait
un groupe et en est venu à se motiver
pour venir tout nettoyer via leur compte
instagram millions dépollution il
appelle les lyonnais à se mobiliser pour
nettoyer les quais ce samedi ils étaient
entre 200 et 250 à se rassembler sur le
pont de la guillotière
en passant au peigne fin une zone de 1,5
kilomètre de long en ramassant toutes
sortes de déchets et les plus sensibles
à l'écologie à lyon ne sont pas
forcément ceux qu'on croit la majorité a
besoin de ce que j'ai retenu taui
clairement c'est entre 16 et 18 ans il
ya même des personnes qui sont au
collège je crois que ça descend vers 13
ans et personne ou deux puis en 13 ans
et on a quelques adultes quelques
parents mais quand même relativement peu
et on espère que pour les kings
prochaine ira voilà plus un poids encore
un petit peu plus jeunes encore plus de
parents et le plus de monde possible de
la seconde extraordinaire on est plus de
200 m semble scénario beaucoup de jeunes
et une forte mobilisation qui
sensibilise également la métropole de
lyon la ville va mettre en place de
nouveaux bacs de tri et de grandes
poubelles pour inciter les lyonnais à
jeter et trier leurs déchets sur les
quais des berges qui devrait voir tout
de même leur fréquentation baisser avec
la réouverture des bars et des terrasses